So let's look at the relatively
simple implementation of a barrier
in a program.
So this is our barrier implementation.
Our counter is a shared variable, and
everybody's trying to increment it
when they arrive to the variable.
Multiple threads could arrive to
the variable at about the same time.
So we have to protect
the counter using a lock.
So here what we are really
doing is counting the arrivals.
Once we are done incrementing the
counter we can check if the counter is
equal to the total.
If it is, that means that we
are either the last thread.
Or the last thread has arrived.
Note that the two are not
necessarily the same.
We may be able to increment the counter,
but we are not the last thread.
But, by the time we get to check the
total, the last thread has arrived and
increments the counter.
So, we read the counter that is not
the same as what we left it with.
Either way,
if the counter is equal to the total.
Then we reset the counter,
because it needs to be re initialized so
that next time we enter the same barrier
variable we have the counted zero.
And we set the release flag to one so
that
the threats who are waiting find out
that the barrier can now be released.
If the count is not equal to the total,
then we're going to spin here waiting
for somebody else to find that the count
is equal to the total end release.
After we are done going through
one instance of this barrier,
the release will be one.
Before we can reuse this barrier,
the release needs to be set at zero and
that's the purpose of this line here.
If we are the first thread to arrive,
then we're going to set release to zero.
So the idea is now that as we enter the
barrier, the first thread that arrives,
and know that this is done
in a critical section,
so exactly one thread will see this
as zero, it sets release to zero.
That thread then increments the count,
it becomes one, and goes on here.
That thread, and all the other threads,
now see release as zero and
the only way it becomes one is
if count reaches the total.
So what happens is the first thread
might actually be delayed and
read the count after everybody's done
in which case it's going to do this.
Or it might go here and spin but
either way, release becoming one means
that somebody got to this point.
Which is when the barrier
should be released.
One or more threads that arrive
towards the end are going to do this,
which will reset the count so that
next time we enter we see count zero.
And release is set to one which
ensures that those threads that didn't
end up here are going to
see release as one.
Note that the meaning of this
spin,release equals one,
is actually that we wait for
release to be one.
It turns out that this barrier
code is not entirely correct.
If two threads are synchronizing on
this barrier, the total will be two.
And the barrier actually
works the first time.
So the thread one reaches the barrier.
And so does thread two.
Now they synchronize on this barrier,
and that will work.
But if we try to continue work,
and then synchronize on the same
barrier variable again, we would expect
that this setting of the count to zero,
and is setting of the release to zero,
to work but it doesn't always work.
So this is not an entirely correct
implementation of a barrier that
can be used more than once.